encore frappé à la porte de Daniel la
porte malheureusement Daniel n'ouvre que
très rarement sa porte dernière fois que
Daniel a ouvert sa porte sachez que
c'est dans un saloon
[Rires]
merci sympa d'être passé Madani
hier soir est-ce que tu allais dîner
avec ton donjon
oui
on a plein plein de points communs on
s'est trouvé plein de points communs et
sans se le dire on a commandé les mêmes
choses donc je te remercie
gambas et noix de saint-jacques rôti
c'est bon et moelleux au chocolat glace
[Applaudissements]
comme il est je lui dis au début du
repas on peut s'enfourer jusque là parce
que c'est Cyril qui régale et bien il a
refusé absolument et c'est lui qui a un
garçon
[Applaudissements]
franchement elle lui est c'est que toi
toi tu as eu un coup de te chat mais de
ouf non mais sans déconner
[Applaudissements]
et il m'a ramené c'est la première fois
toujours
à côté il n'a pas voulu que vous payez
il n'a pas voulu que je prenne un taxi
directement pour l'instant
ou bien là tu as tiré le gros lot moi je
vous dis j'ai jamais été aussi près de
tirer la queue du Mickey
[Applaudissements]
il est célibataire alors on a parlé de
plein de choses on n'a pas été jusque là
pour l'instant
j'ai pas osé c'est pas livré en tout cas
il avait pas de d'alliance
on peut on peut se revoir
[Rires]
quand on n'a pas mangé pendant 30 ans
faut pas tout de suite sauter sur un
plat de merguez c'est une théorie qui
vaut
[Applaudissements]
c'est un proverbe tunisien donc
pour l'instant est-ce que vous avez
échangé les instants ah oui petit texto
aujourd'hui
ça sent bon
mais sûrement mais est-ce que tu as eu
envie de l'embrasser ouais c'est vrai
je viens de loin quand même j'arrive
un peu en tout cas c'est la première
fois
normalement on va sortir sans doute au
théâtre
il aime le théâtre comme moi puis alors
il a un énorme attention
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un très gros je sais pas comment on peut
dire
c'est la première fois que je trouve
midi passe un gros atouts
donc là donc pour l'instant tu vas piano
vassano mais ça franchement c'est la
première fois
[Rires]
tu reçois le sms tu sens tu as ton cœur
qui bat un petit peu plus vite ça fait
Ding dingue
c'est pas ça c'est juste mon seul chez
toi
[Rires]
ça n'a pas tes copines euh non j'ai pas
demandé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai deux trois copains qui me demandent
un peu voilà de faire
de toi copains
quoi qui demande la suite quoi
sans doute aller au théâtre
c'est quitté hier soir
ma technique voilà soyez le coach la
technique c'est l'ignorance
qu'on appelle le blackout
pendant
au moins 24 heures là demain
et après ça fait 30 ans qu'elle se fait
désirer quand même
et le lendemain matin
première heure 8h30
elle l'envoie
d'elle toute nue en train de manger des
chocs
[Applaudissements]
c'est une base
[Rires]
t'inquiète pas bon en tout cas ça avance
bien
en tout cas hier on était tous hyper
content pour toi mais il y a une
personne que j'ai eu hier au téléphone
est-ce que tu te souviens d'un fameux
Thierry que tu as rencontré cet été dans
un gala est-ce que tu te souviens il
avait vraiment eu un coup de
coeurs et il y avait ce Thierry à ta
table et il était vraiment il était
vraiment à fond sur toi et tu ne lui as
plus jamais donné de nouvelles ah bah
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
était était fermé donc il t'a laissé
tranquille mais quand il a vu la
séquence d'hier m'a téléphoné il m'a dit
donc en fait Daniel elle est ouverte à
des nouvelles rencontres j'ai dit
apparemment oui et il était
[Applaudissements]
c'est le soldat c'est le seul gars
avant Daniel il était surface
cet après-midi à mon avis il a dû
m'appeler lui aussi
désolé
je ne rigole pas tu as une cote de merde
là je viens de découvrir en fait dans un
une espèce de niche il y avait j'ai des
décors
attention à un moment ça va c'est la
route bien sûr attends je te jure
attention
et là je vais te dire celui dit celui
dire il est incroyable
mais c'est difficile il
quelque chose qui me chiffonne un peu
c'est qu'il est beaucoup plus jeune que
moi ah bon alors
franchement
ça passe crème hein
en plus toi tu vas vivre hyper vieille
non mais sans déconner toi parti comme
tu es parti
l'autoroute du bonheur
non mais je te dis tu sais celle qui est
celle qui va le vivre le plus longtemps
elle bougera plus parce que ça c'est pas
utilisé ça
[Rires]